hallo mein Name ist Luc und herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren Quiz in den
letzten Folgen von diesen Quiz Videos
auf teste dich haben wir ja immer Quizes
beantwortet was wir heute allerdings
machen werden ist ein eigenes Quiz
erstellen deswegen bin ich hier auf
dieser Seite quizerstellung Schritt 1
und werde das jetzt machen sie haben
sich für ein W falsch Quiz entschieden
Wissensquiz und fantest nur eine Antwort
ist korrekt sie können selbst angen ob
die W oder falsche Antwort richtig GEW
fals Quiz bla bitte geben Sie auf jeden
Fall ich nenne das ganze das Luca
Quiz weil es über mich geht als
Einleitung schreiben mir mal alle wenn
es so ein Quiz über mich oder ein
anderen Youtuber ist so ja Youtuber XY
ist voll cool finde heraus ob du auch so
cool bist oder wie viel du weißt und son
ein shit hier findest Du zehn Fragen die
du mit wahr oder falsch beantworten
sollst finde heraus wie gut du Luca
kennst mache ich jetzt einfach mal als
Einleitung mein Name ist Luca und meine
E-Mailadresse ist
kcrafter@gmail.com weiter bitte machen
Sie während der quizerstellung keine
Pausen pro Formular haben Sie ca 10
Minuten
Zeit was meine Videos gehen in der
rotteil immer so eine halbe Stunde ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das innerhalb
von 10 Minuten schaffen soll was ist
sein
Lieblingsessen und
dann ach es ist ja ein wahr oder falsch
Quiz ist Burger sein
Lieblingsessen und dann machen wir
einfach mal
als jetzt seht ihr ja sogar schon
was ich da mache ich habe jetzt einfach
mal W oder falsch gerade angeklickt und
bin jetzt bei Frage 2 einfach damit ihr
das nicht seht das heißt wir machen
jetzt quasi nur die Fragen zusammen und
danach das ist total die dumme Videoidee
als zweite Frage mache ich jetzt einfach
mal nimmt Luca seine Videos immer in
Unterhose auf seine shopadresse lautet
luca-shop.com sein kleiner plüchhund
Balu besitzt ein besitzt habe ich falsch
geschrieben besitzt eine rote Schleife
Luca mag Berlin das sind jetzt alles so
Sachen die sehr die nur Leute wissen die
mir wahrscheinlich irgendwie bei
snapchat folgen oder irgendwie sehr
häufig meine Videos schauen oder was
weiß ich deswegen das ist schon ein sehr
schwieriges Quiz in vitello befindet
sich kein Leitungswasser luca ist immer
ausgeschlafen fit und clever luca ist
der
coolste ne das kann ich nicht nehmen
Alter nahzu jedes seiner Videos
beinhaltet eine Kooperation mit einem
anderen Youtuber lasas spielt einmal pro
Woche Minecraft auf seinem Kanal er
kommt aus Bielefeld quizerstellung
Schritt 2 Auswertungen bis zu vier
richtigen Antworten Auswertung bis zu
sechs richtigen Antworten jetzt
muss ich noch ein Text schreiben weißt
überhaupt wie Luca buchstabiert wird man
könnte meinen du wüsstest wer er
überhaupt
ist Blödmann Auswertungen bis zu a
richtigen Antworten ja gut
das war's hey Spitze du bist ja richtig
Schau wollen sie den Quiz Teilnehmer
nachdem die dieses Quiz gemacht haben
die Möglichkeit geben sich richtig
Antwort anzuschauen nein sollen die
Fragen auf einer Seite angezeigt werden
wo jede fr pro Frage eine Seite wie viel
Sekunden soll der serfver Zeit haben um
eine Frage und das Quiz zu lösen bitte
lassen das FT leer wenn es
keine Alter soll ich mal machen pro
Frage eine Sekunde wir machen kein
Zeitlimit klicken auf Speichern und ist
eine Vorschau bitte das Speich nicht
vergessen das Luca Quiz hier findest Du
zehn Fragen die du mit wahr falsch
beantworten sollst finde heraus wie gut
du Lua kennst oh ich habe was
wahrscheinlich was hier unter gerade ist
komplett zensiert weil da stehen die
richtigen Antworten sie haben es
geschafft ihr Quiz wurde erstellt sie
finden ihr Quiz auf der folgenden Seite
oh mein Gott wir können das schon
anschauen das Luca Quiz hier findest Du
zehn Fragen die mit wahr oder falsch
beantworten sollst finde heraus wie gut
du Luca kennst wieso habe ich den bin
ich gut im Bett als vorgeschlagene
scheiße hier Burger sein Lieblingsessen
war nimmt l seine Videos me Unterhose
auf falsch die haben drei von zehn
Aufgaben richtig beantwortet weißt
überhaupt wie Luca buchstabiert wird ich
bin gut im Durchschnitt haben die ein
Surfer die das Quiz gemacht haben drei
richtige Antworten abgegeben Alter was
ein Zufall ich bin genau im Durchschnitt
ja ich habe jetzt auf jeden Fall dieses
Quiz gemacht wenn ich jetzt oben mal
eingebe das Luca Quiz dann komme ich
übrigens dann ist das dann ist das Quiz
tats warum nur Luca Henny wer war denn
noch mal Luca Henny ich packe euch mal
den Link von diesem Quiz in die
Beschreibung ihr könnt das dann zocken
ich das ist keine Kooperation mit der
Website oder irgendwie dass ich Geld
dafür bekomme euch das grü zu geben oder
ich habe auch nichts davon wenn ihr das
spielt das ist einfach nur weil ich
dachte es macht Spaß zusammen ein Quiz
zu erstellen
aber weil es eigentlich nicht so nice
ihr könnt dieses Quiz ja dann einfach
mal machen wenn du da Bock drauf mehr
Quizes von Luca ach ich kann einfach nur
schauen welche Quizes es noch gibt ich
dachte jetzt es wäre so ein Quiz so W in
dem Quiz so fragenestellt werden soll
Luca noch mehr Quizes machen auf seinem
Kanal aber na ja das Quiz was ihr machen
könnt ist in der beschreib wenn ich
nicht vergesse ich weiß nicht wieso
welche Youtuberin bist du am ähnlichsten
wie reif bist du wirklich und bist du
hübsch da drunter angezeigt wird das
kann auch nicht sein wenn euch das Video
gefallen hat meine Damen her würde ich
mich über eine Bewertung freuen ihr
könnt mir auch weitere Tests in die
Kommentare schreiben beispielsweise so
Luca teste doch mal ob du eine müllonne
bist oder vielleicht auch ein
Engel
okay